newly released documents about former
Trump campaign advisor Carter page show
how the FBI decided to wiretap him much
of the information is blacked out but
the FBI claims page was targeted for
recruitment by Russia's government page
denies it saying he has never been an
agent of a foreign power the president
and his defenders say the FBI did not
disclose that the wiretap warrant was
based on information from a political
source but the new release shows the FBI
did list the source of the information
Paula Reid is at the Justice Department
Paula what did we learn from this FISA
application all of the evidence that the
government presented to the FISA Court
when it wanted to surveil Carter page
and in this application they refer to
him as a quote agent of a foreign
government and they say that they
believe there was an active campaign by
the Russian government to recruit him as
a spine as you noted Paige has denied
all of these allegations what was also
interesting in this 400 page application
was that this really undercuts
Republican claims that the FBI abused
its surveillance power and failed to
disclose the origins of the so-called
steel dossier that research that was
done on President Trump and his campaign
because if you look at this application
there's over a page long explanation of
the steel dossier and its origins and
the fact that it may have been supported
with some by someone with an anti-trump
bias now also interesting is that the
four judges who approve this
surveillance they were all appointed by
Republican presidents
all right Paul one other question
slightly different matters is the
Michael Cohen the president's lawyer was
apparently who I recorded a conversation
he had with the president what do we
know about that well we know this
recording lasted several minutes about
two two or so minutes and we know that
he and the president discussed a payment
to former Playboy model Karen McDougal
but what we don't know is whether or not
this discussive payment that was
actually saved to her we also don't know
why Cowan chose to record this
conversation but it appears that by
discussing it the president's lawyers
have waived any privilege that he could
have claimed thanks Paul